well greets héctor mejía with the
most outstanding news of the day two
people were found dead after
a possible case of homicide suicide in
henderson according to official authorities they
arrived at a home last night
near sandwich hyde park way seven
hills drive for a
welfare check  a 25-
year-old woman and a 29-year-old man were found
dead detectives only said it was
a possible murder suicide
today the city of las vegas will decide
whether to allow marijuana dispensaries to
sell their products by
drive-through or drive-thru la
clark county board of commissioners approved
a similar measure last summer
today's proposal would allow
dispensaries within the city of las
vegas to open drive-thru windows as
long as certain
safety and egress measures are followed
and another proposal to be addressed at
the city council meeting has
to do with the trucks that sell
to  food a group of merchants is
asking for the approval of a lot of
land so that
food trucks can be parked in
the downtown arts district last month
the board of commissioners approved
the project near the streets that without
the  sir charles however since
then some
business and restaurant owners in the area have
shown their opposition to the idea and
are now asking the city council to
reconsider their decision
registrations are being accepted for
the program known as safety which
offers activities to  children before and
after school are currently
only accepting students from kindergarten to
third year and they will only be able to use the
program during the days that they take their
classes in person for more
information call 70 22 29 54 37
we also have the website at  our home
page dotcom
now a look at what awaits us in
terms of weather it's ash wednesday
l  he winds have taken a break but
we will still have some max breezes
around 60 by this afternoon
northerly winds will go up to 25 or
30 miles per hour during the day have
a nice day and take care I am hector
mejia and this was your brief  informative
txt or in Spanish